[music playing]
NARRATOR: The sub will
dive to the wreck site,
travel over the bow, then
out across the debris field,
searching for the
mysterious piece of metal.
Here comes the water attempt.
Tom, are you ready?
Yeah, roger that,
my hatch is secure.
Roger that, hatch
secure, here we go.
Roger that.
If we could get a little
bit more on there.
NARRATOR: If Parks's
theory is correct,
it'll be an incredible
discovery, connecting
a family across generations.
Cleared to go ahead
and start pumping.
There goes the submerge.
[radio chatter]
This is the LF, go ahead?
You're cleared
to start pumping.
[radio chatter]
It's clear.
I have armed thrusters.
We are beginning to pump in now.
NARRATOR: The sub
begins its long descent.
Benjamin Guggenheim was
born into a wealthy mining
family in Philadelphia in 1865.
He was 47 years old when Titanic
sank, leaving behind a wife
and three young daughters.
Surface LF, depth
3805, heading 310.
Life support good.
Wreck on sonar.
Roger that, LF.
Understand 3805 meters heading
310 degrees, with life support
good and wreck on sonar.
Congratulations.
NARRATOR: The sub has
reached the wreck site.
PARKS STEPHENSON:
God, it's murky.
VICTOR VESCOVO: You can look
down there and see for--
[interposing voices]
PARKS STEPHENSON:
I can see it, yeah.
Actually, the visibility
is better looking down.
(LAUGHING) Yes it is.
There's the Marconi
room, one of the windows,
one of the skylights.
VICTOR VESCOVO:
Oh, let's see here.
NARRATOR: Before searching for
the remains of the Guggenheim
state rooms, the team
films additional footage
of other important features
for later analysis,
including the area around
the captain's quarters.
OK, I can barely see it.
Barely see it, and
yeah, it's devastated.
I see a glimpse of the tub.
NARRATOR: Next, the team turns
their attention to the search
for Guggenheim's staterooms.
The debris field is 15
square miles in size.
Finding a single piece
of metal is like trying
to find a needle in a haystack.
Is this the bigger piece?
No, it's not the bigger piece.
What is this?
PARKS STEPHENSON: I don't
think it's Guggenheim either.
NARRATOR: Parks is searching
for specific structural features
that coincide with
the stateroom's
location aboard the ship.
This is key to confirming
the identity of the mystery
object in the image.
We've got something
up there on the left.
Yep.
40 meters.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, eyes
out, eyes out, eyes out.
OK.
PARKS STEPHENSON: This might
be the Guggenheim piece.
You see all that ribbing?
Yeah.
This might be the
Guggenheim piece.
I'm going to translate left.
You translate
left, yes, please.
Yep, here we go, that is it.
This is it, this is Guggenheim's
stateroom right here.
Right here.
VICTOR VESCOVO: Found it.
That's the
stateroom right there.
That's Guggenheim.
Good job.
Teamwork.
Surface, LF, present
depth 3802, life support
good, at Guggenheim.
Roger, LF, at Guggenheim.
Congratulations.
[music playing]